bon allez c'est ça va françois une tomme
encore rien j'étais bon ton cheval est
prêt aussi bon cheval est très bien bon
bah on va pouvoir commencer le film non
d'accord allait vite et finalement non
tout le cheval voilà je suis prêt
casimir ça tourne à temps kazemi
ça va pas mais enfin transféré ce qui
compte c'est complètement fou c'est pas
du tout le texte du film c'est julie qui
vont parler la première mais justement
c'est pour ça que ça va pas elle est en
train de se maquiller son camp mais ça
fait presque une demi heure c'est
casimir c'est important pour elle c'est
la première fois qu'elle joue dans un
film
alors elle veut être très très belle
afin d'être tout à fait naturel et plus
et maquillage doit être discret mais il
est loin réalisé doit voir quand il va
se retourner sera surpris se rencontrent
jeudi
et d'habitude et singulis brad on savoir
pourquoi mais c'est formidable alors ça
voilà c'est fini tu vas voir comme elle
est très jolie
voilà la réponse tout indique que les
nuits je crois que tu lui a fait peur à
bout non non non non je n'ai pas eu peur
voilà le grand metteur en scène casimir
n'a peur de rien annie te fâche on
commence à l'eva tout le monde en place
bon alors voilà bien que je pouvais
manivelle françois descend du cheval et
toi tu t'approches de lui pour
l'accueillir un bon prix on y va alors
on y va vous êtes prêts oui
attention ça tourne à
salut chérie c'est vraiment sympa de
votre part de nos envies mais non julie
ça ne va pas du tout tu es la fille du
grand chef indien pour ce bavard qui ne
peut pas dire ça nous charries bon pour
aller on recommence à mort voilà
attention bon ça vous monsieur le shérif
permettez moi de vous souhaiter la
bienvenue dans ce voyage mais non non
maintenant on dirait monsieur du snob ou
moi je comprends pas ce que tu veux tuer
la fille d'un grand chef indien
oui alors tu dois parler comme les
indiens comme les indiens mais oui c'est
pourtant très facile enfin écoute je
vais te montrer dix mois exactement ce
que je t'ai demandé de faire eh ben tu
m'as demandé d'accueillir le shérif avec
l'amabilité en vertu des règles de
l'hospitalité qui sont sacrés chez les
indiens et de laisser transparaître une
certaine méfiance mêmes yeux une
certaine agressivité mais c'est pas
facile mais si c'est très facile tu vas
voir
bon allez françois monte sur ton cheval
mais moi une perruque ce sera plus
facile
voilà attention ouais regarde bien
vas-y tu as compris rien du tout tu as
fait salou oui oui oui mais c'est très
simple hugues signifie un indien
soyez les bienvenus je vous accueille
selon les lois de l'hospitalité promu
usage chez nous les indiens
mais malgré tout avec une certaine dose
de méfiance des mêmes d'agressivité qui
a tous à nous tous mais oui absolument
tu vas voir je vais rejouer la scène 90
yens
attention françois remonte sur son
chemin elle enfin voyons au col en quoi
encore on ne critique pas les ordres du
grand metteur en scène quasi n'y ait
vraiment ce que tu sais mon attention
les yeux moi ni venir fumée calumet de
la paix visages pâles avoir la langue
fourchue mois à attendre de connaître
motifs de sa visite à la grand chef
blanc a chargé de te remettre ces
magnifiques trésors en échange de trois
chariots remplis de ce métal jaune sans
valeur que vous avez 1 1 dans vos
montagnes ou visage pâle me croient
aussi bête d'un chien de prairie
nous parlerons de ça au grand conseil
avec bison gloubi les buffalos bullguard
tu crois qu'ils ont dénoué mien mais
while alors maintenant qui va me
critiquer pourront aussi comme monsieur
douces notes ont de bons joueurs mais
service n'a qu'à ses débuts et
merveilleusement bien mes chers amis
mais je vois tous déguisés et même
casimir qui porte une perruque qui lui
va à ravir
ne critiquez pas casimir ne vous moquez
pas guéri nous allons faire un grand
film julie et moi
les enfants sont les principaux acteurs
enfin presque et casimir le metteur en
scène fait que l'événement est
d'importance et ça et comment
s'appellera ce petit chef-d'oeuvre
françois julie et les autres oui oui oui
c'est bien ce que je pensais un mauvais
titre cache mauvaise histoire
enfin heureusement que j'ai dans ma tête
une histoire qui fera un film formidable
mais les messieurs qui se nomme
l'histoire de casimir etrabonne notre un
très bon film vous voulez qu'ils
voulaient raconte nous nous n'aurons pas
de temps à perdre mais je voulais vous
dis merci casimir je suis heureux te
faire plaisir entre remplaçants dans ton
rôle de metteur en scène mon film
s'appellera le shérif des ballons perdus
oui c'est l'histoire d'un shérif qui
veut tromper la fille d'un grand chef
indien en lui et changeant trois
malheureux petit ballon qu'entre
trois énormes chariot de métal jaune
c'est à dire de l'ain mais monsieur vie
ce ne fût n'hésitez pas mais vous m'avez
pris une histoire quoi on nous fait tout
est pareil vous m'avait volé mon film
mais pas de tout de toi qui a volé mon
histoire mais oui à quoi
mais que se passe-t-il mes amis un
sombre drame
monsieur du jeune homme et casimir
s'accusent mutuellement de s'être volé
l'idée d'une histoire mais nous
n'arrivons pas à savoir qui dit vrai
mais nous allons juste commencé mon film
mais oui tout est perdu apprécié d'un
non rien n'est perdu
je viens de lire livres la bibliothèque
de l'île aux enfants qui pour sûr fera
un excellent sujet de film et il vous
remettra tous d'accord bien c'est
parfait
quelle est l'histoire racontée vite
facteurs et bien voilà c'est l'histoire
d'un shérif un chef qui veut changer des
ballons contre des chariots d'or à la
fille d'un chef indien
vous avez dit oui et d'ailleurs casimir
et monsieur du snob connaissent bien ce
livre ils ont lu je les ai vus sur le
fichier de la bibliothèque pas vrai
monsieur des snobs
où
[Musique]
à